[Music]
plastique hi thank you for coming on
into Canada pride oh thank you for
having me I'm so excited to have you
here and I was a little nervous because
I know the work the World Tour was
crossing the border and whenever that
happens mmm there's a bit of fear that
it's not gonna happen yeah I appreciate
you hustling to get here girl she got
her back into the cat but I'm here now
so it's all good laughing me oh my gosh
any time I have to say first and
foremost you're stunning oh here's the
three thank you I'm sure you get that a
lot
it's a
brings out that fun go in that plastic
tear out cool big nap
I loved you on season 11 of RuPaul's
Drag Race tell me about that experience
of being on the show
was it everything you have hoped for and
more um not it's a lot different being
on the show than watching it on TV for
sure there's a lot more work involved
behind the scenes and you know you
filmed for 15 hours a day and I could
cut to like five minutes you know so
it's a lot more work but I was happy for
what I see on TV and it just goes to
show like how I mean I really appreciate
how much work goes into a production
like that and no I was very happy I was
on the show it's a it's a strange
environment reality TV though right like
you said like you shoot probably 15
hours a day and then it gets edited down
into this condensed version that's 45
minutes yep sure was there anything that
you would have liked to see from your
own story on the show that may have
gotten cut um I mean I mean have fun the
like the first like eight episodes I was
like damn I have no camera time like
where am I on this show but when finally
I have the episode I won I kind of like
everything was all about Mia so I would
say at that point I was very happy but
on that episode I from my experience on
the show I wish things would have just
like you know I would spoken my mind a
little bit more clarify some things cuz
being on this show I didn't know that so
many people will confuse and so many
people were like you know questioning
she got information from rue because of
a sob story that she told but according
to the video people know about her
situation so your story is not the truth
oh my gosh I didn't like okay this is
your story and you're trying to tell
your truth and then there's people I
mean we maybe don't have to mention
names I roll I roll hi roll Raja
and that's the team but she I mean there
was wig gate which involved you super
annoying his wig gate settled now I
don't know as you can see from the
finale we like the audience still don't
know we chucked light the more we try to
settle things the more crazy it gets so
I'm just gonna let it go yeah and I mean
again a Roger brought up questions about
your story and thinking that what you
were saying was insincere or not true
yeah where does that stand now um I
think after the show because during
while filming like I thought we were all
good you know like I had talked to her
have talked to uh curious
everybody kind of like you know we've
written a good place and then watching
it back on the show I was like oh I got
the word not a good place and then the
fans comes into play too and the band's
art for RuPaul's Drag Race are lovely we
love you but they're insane
yep very interesting very interesting
I'm not really problematic so I didn't
know how kind of like to deal with the
reaction yeah and so I just kind of like
girl just text me like you know that
whole Twitter thing back and forth back
and forth back and forth about my number
right like text me hello I was like can
you just call me la I know like the show
is happening but we're still people we
still have phones were still have
emotion so just call me text me and like
just don't bring it up so on social
media and stir it up this huge pie but
afterwards we kind of talked and then
she kind of just like night told me
basically like the fans we're getting to
her and then it's not like me kind of
thing it's about what's going on inside
so I know I mean I don't blame her and
if she were coming for me that I could
give her well it is a reality TV show
but you had one of the most emotional
moments I would say in maybe all 11
seasons when I was watching that that
moment with Drew this is an opportunity
for you to show them in a way
on your own terms beautiful
and creative and this is your gift to
not only them but to yourself tell me
about where things are now and where
they stand with your family since you've
been on the show um funny thing is that
during the show Wow the show first aired
I didn't know how much of an impact the
show has made like worldwide and my
grandparents they come back and forth
from Vietnam and the state's a lot and I
would come visit them and when I came
back my grandpa kind of like put his
hand on my shoulder and he was like I'm
very proud of you
and I didn't know what I was for and
apparently I have a really big following
in Vietnam and the show has reached that
far and my family members actually like
my extended family members found out
that I was on the show and told him that
you should be very proud of Duke my boy
named because he's made it in American
television which is very hard for an
Asian immigrant little boy to do but I
don't know if he knows that I dressed up
as a woman on TV or not but you just
said that he's very proud of me so that
just goes to show how grateful I am and
that how happy I am for this platform my
mom on the other hand is you know she
knows what I do she saw like you know
like videos and stuff and she's you know
proud of me because I've you know made
my name it's kind of like enough it's
not accepting but it's tolerating I'm
acknowledging I've know alleging that
I'm doing something in the world so it's
getting there so hold on you know it
sometimes takes a bit of time for
parents or siblings or friends to accept
port or what we do or sure and I've come
to the realities realization that you
know it might not not never happen yeah
and that's okay that's okay but you're
gonna be you yeah but best of my family
I still love them well you have an
amazing drag family you come from house
of Edwards
yeah Alyssa is amazing the one though
one Alyssa Edwards is just the ultimate
yet also shangela shangela has been on
this show before yeah love
what do you love about being part of
that house I mean I might be a little
biased but it's my drive family it's
very ELISA is one of the first people
who you know when I first started like I
was a baby Queen several months into
drag
we got booked together and then she was
the first person somebody that you're
gonna be a star over and from that point
on it and I had idolized her so much you
know like being like 19 years old and
just be like oh my god it's Elizabeth
Edwards just somebody of her like status
at the time like telling like me or like
a baby queen that she just met like
you're gonna be a star is just she just
has an amazing heart and I just I'm just
very grateful to be a part of this
extended legacy amazing a legacy yeah
and we're we have a mutual friend
actually I don't know that or not but I
want you to take a look at that screen
right there oh god here we go
our mutual friend has sent something in
hello my sweetest angel a quick question
for you who's your favorite mother me or
Alyssa choose wisely Brooklyn Heights
Brooklyn Heights is a good friend of the
show and you're a good friend of
Brooklyn I love Brooklyn so she was
gracious enough to send that in but I
guess you have to answer her question
he's the better drag mommy Wow
if I have to decide what has to be
that's the bus money that's that's a
very smart and I have so many track
mothers now I don't even know who is my
real drive home anymore we're in the
Queen of the North's country so that why
I got hell at the border today you had
called inside hey yeah this redheaded
right here slide something
what's your own personal favorite look
of yourself from your time on RuPaul's
Drag Race do you have one that you just
love um I love my finale look at the
finale where I got to wear my
traditional Ali I Soviet nice dress it's
something that I have wanted for a long
time and no one has ever done on drag
race before and it was a very special
moment for me to represent my culture
and just like it was like go wider what
how they say it
what do you still dream of doing because
I know you've put a music and music
video out yeah
[Music]
are you gonna do more music oh I don't
know I feel like it's a it's in the root
girl rulebook to put out a music video
once you get eliminate from the shell it
was a beauty Oh Oh a lot of drag root
girls videos really good thank you it
was really fun to film as well but I
don't know like I just kind of just want
to dabble and everything and see why I
find like fits my style best and I don't
know I just kind of want to do
everything I guess the next journey is
to just conquer the world and well I my
face out there I have to say when you
walked in today we haven't met before
but I'm like holy shoot holy shoot
you're tall like I can see you stomping
down a runway sound lands which would be
amazing thank you that's kind of what I
want to go for you know kind of just cuz
direct right now is just so mainstream
already I would love to see drag queens
on the runway drag queens on covers of
magazines like Vogue has what got a
billion magazines out now and not one of
them is on the cover like RuPaul lady
yes that's a great aliens RuPaul but can
you imagine like a cover of Vogue with
Roe and all of the drag girls oh my god
like oh my god not just the whole page
so though we could do one of those full
doe covers where there's like 15
different pages are you watching drag
race UK right now I love it um those
queens are really funny so funny like
honestly the bet like the best track
race well Japanese Thailand's pretty
good but it was like one of the best
like episodes I've seen it's so good who
are you who's plastic rooting for right
now
I'm drunk UK iy bag of chips freakin
make it to the end I think she is such a
star she has just so much star power
that's just incredible it's so funny
he's so charismatic anything she can do
anything she does is amazing to me
because you have had such a journey on
the show I grown so much from my time
being here and you show me how to be
myself and for that I thank you you are
meeting people all the time at drag Con
and different events and backstage
what's a message that you send that
plastique sends to maybe people in
Vietnam who are looking up to you right
now and our members of the lgbtq+
community
what do you send to them as a bit of
inspiration from what you've learned um
I would tell them to just dream big and
then work towards it okay
I never thought that I would be here and
I never thought I would go in drag race
at you know a month after I turned 21
and doing all that but I had a dream and
I saved up money and I worked towards it
and it's where I am now so honestly
anything is possible
so if you work towards it you'll get
there I'm a hundred percent with you and
that and I'm a firm believer of putting
out to the universe what you want we
also have to work for it for sure for
sure
right well plastique one last thing I
have to ask you oh my god all-stars five
everybody wants to know because I mean
if you're going on deep dives in reddit
everybody wants to see prosti stars five
is also something you'd be willing to do
um I would say that I would love to do
all-stars when I'm ready
when I feel like it's my time is when I
I will go back yeah
well but only when it's my time I never
say never I never say never
yeah well thank you so much for hanging
out with me this was a lot of fun I
could talk to you forever
oh so what you would know yeah there's a
lot of fun thanks for taking my life
[Music]